today on the matt walsh show the media
obtained president trump's tax records
uh the big scandal is that trump managed
to legally keep a lot of his own money
somehow i'm just not able to feel much
outrage about this though the media
wants me to
also five headlines including another
revelation that jacob blake shooting and
amy coney barrett is officially
announced as trump's scotus pick the
attacks from the left have been as
deranged as expected but we'll go over
some of them plus the daily cancellation
much more all that on the way first
a message from lifelock you know it's uh
it's really easy for someone to steal
your information especially if you're
not being responsible and protecting it
when you're online we think about
protecting our homes right lock the
doors maybe have security system
we take measures there while your data
is a lot more vulnerable
than your home yet very often we aren't
as focused on protecting it
we should be identity theft has become a
big time crime with criminal gangs
operating units dedicated just to that
certain behavior can make you more
vulnerable to identity theft like not
checking your credit card or your bank
statements
using the same username and password on
every account never checking your credit
report
over sharing personal information on
social media i mean a lot of us are
guilty of
all of these things or at least many of
them it's important to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet and
you could miss
certain identity threats just by
monitoring your credit
that's why it's great that there's
lifelock life lot can detect a wide
range
of identity threats like your social
security number being for sale in the
dark web
and if they detect your information
they're going to send you an alert so
you're going to know
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can find out if your
information is for sale on the dark web
get your free dark web scan at
lifelock.com
walsh pick this the plan that's right
for you and save up to 25
off your first year with promo code
walsh that's a free scan at lifelock.com
walsh and 25 off with promo code walsh
all right well you know i think back to
uh
2018 all those
centuries ago it feels like when michael
cohen trump's lawyer and fixer
his harvey keitel from pulp fiction his
guy who
goes in and figures out how to how to
hide the bodies you know that's what we
were told anyway
when that guy turned on trump and
revealed that he had been secretly
recording conversations with his former
boss
and he gave those tapes to the media now
think about that a guy who is now
president of the united states a guy who
we're told is corrupt down to his bones
has been secretly recorded by his lawyer
and the media has the tapes what sort of
deep
dark dirty misdeeds will they uncover
one can only imagine except one need not
imagine it's on tape
what a score well then cnn played the
tapes
and they weren't nearly as exciting as
we had hoped or anticipated
mostly they just discussed normal
business dealings at one point they
apparently talk about buying the rights
to a story about a playboy model who
says she had an affair with trump but
you can't even really hear trump's part
of the conversation regardless
listening to the tapes you know an
honest person couldn't help but think
well if this is the worst thing they
have in secret recordings between trump
and his lawyer then
maybe he isn't the criminal mastermind
that cnn wants us to believe he is
it's the same thing with all the
tell-all books the various white house
house officials leaving the
administration
turning around and revealing everything
that happened
they have they have some things that
they say that you know aren't very
flattering to trump
though you can't necessarily believe all
of it anyway but
we've been told that trump is the
embodiment of evil he's corrupt he's
criminal he's a russian asset he's a
fascist warlord you'd expect some
indication of that
when all of these secrets are dumped out
in front of the public
instead we're always left with the
impression that if the stuff is true
trump is kind of a jerk which we already
knew but
he isn't the mob boss the media wants
him to be
and then we add to this the fbi
investigations the impeachment
they've gone through every aspect of
trump's life and business looking for
skeletons and they haven't really found
them which at a certain point
makes a rational man conclude maybe
there are no skeletons
all of this comes to mind when when
reading about the next big media scoop
that's supposed to bring down trump for
real this time no for real for real this
time the new york times has obtained
trump's tax records
and by obtained of course we mean that
someone trump trusted with his finances
turned around and gave it to the media
if there's any crime
uncovered here it's that the crime is in
the uncovering
not in the thing that was uncovered what
do the uh tax records
reveal well the website dnyuz.com has
helpfully given us the bullet points so
i'll read them here
mr trump paid no federal income taxes
and 11 of 18 years that the times
examined
in 2017 after he became president his
tax bill was only 750
he has reduced his tax bill with
questionable measures including a 72.9
million
tax refund that's the subject of an
audit by the irs many of his signature
businesses including his golf courses
report
losing large amounts of money losses
that have helped him to lower his taxes
uh the financial pressure on him is
increasing as hundreds of millions of
dollars in loans
he personally guaranteed are soon coming
due even while declaring losses he has
managed to enjoy a lavish lifestyle by
by taking tax deductions on what would
most people would consider
personal expenses including residences
aircraft
and seventy thousand dollars in hair
styling for tv
ivanka trump while working as an
employee of the trump organization
appears to have received consulting fees
that also helped reduce the family's tax
bill
and then it says as president he has
received more money from foreign sources
and u.s interest groups
than previously known the records do not
reveal
any previously unreported connections to
russia
now to be clear here clear here there is
no
known crime involved in any of this the
refund
that they talked about that's
questionable is in audit right now it's
going through the proper channels
the rest of it is entirely legal and
above board
once again we have the same effect even
if you don't like the fact
that trump paid so little in taxes if
he's a crook
you'd expect his personal financial
records to reveal something more than
that he's creative in his tax deductions
and not even that creative actually the
media is making a lot of the fact that
trump
as i mentioned deducted his hair styling
expenses for tv
but all of the media people panicking
over it are doing their panicking
with professionally styled hair and
professional makeup
the studios that they're in have
stylists and makeup artists on staff
if any of those media people had to pay
for it themselves they'd be deducting it
too
it's a completely legitimate deduction
for a tv personality any accountant of a
tv personality that doesn't tell them to
deduct those sorts of things
is guilty of malpractice there's really
nothing strange about it and that's the
case for most of this at least as far as
the taxes go
trump took advantage of the tax law to
mitigate his tax liability as much as
possible
if you don't if you don't like that he
could mitigate it that much
take it up with the people who write the
tax law trump is working within the
boundaries of the law if you think those
boundaries should be tightened
your qualm is not with trump who had
nothing to do with
setting the boundaries in the first
place now
i admit i'm biased okay personally i
have never
been able to generate significant
emotional outrage against people who
manage to keep most of their own money
at tax time
even illegally criminal tax evasion
which isn't what this is
but just to give you an idea of my own
leanings full disclosure
even criminal tax evasion doesn't make
me very angry i reserve
most of my moral disgust and outrage for
child rapists
murderers people of that sort those
guilty of stealing their own money from
the irs just don't raise my hackles to
be honest with you
but if they do it legally as trump did
well then
not only am i not outraged but i admire
your ingenuity
or at least the ingenuity of your
accountants and i like their numbers
if i recognize any serious moral
obligation when it comes to taxes
it's to keep as much of your hard-earned
money as you can
you certainly have no moral obligation
to pay one dime more to the irs
than is required many of us do pay more
than is required but not intentionally
if you intentionally do it you're not
you're not moral you're a sucker you're
a sap
you're probably clinically insane
actually listen the government already
brings in over three trillion dollars a
year in taxes three trillion dollars
that's enough money that if you put it
all in a stack it would nearly reach the
moon
again i say that our moral obligation is
to contribute as little
to that grotesque behemoth pile as we
can
the government takes way too much and
wastes way too much
only give it what it forces you to not
one penny more than that
and this has always been my opinion i i
mean i didn't come up with it now to
defend trump
it's just that i'm not going to make an
exception in order to criticize trump
which is what most people in the media
do
i mean just be honest here for a minute
let's say that your accountant if you
have one comes to you and says hey
you're going to owe 5 000 in taxes but
you forgot to to deduct
this and that and you also forgot to
claim this and that and if you do all
that
you'll actually get a 500 refund now i
ask
who among us would respond no that's
okay i'll pay the five grand
who among us if you actually don't want
that five grand
then give it to charity give it to a
struggling family member
hell give it to me i'll take it don't
give it to the irs
anything but that it would be a greater
moral deed to stuff it down the garbage
disposal than to give it to the irs when
you don't actually
legally owe it of course you could point
out that the real problem here
is that rich people are able to navigate
and take advantage of the tax code
while the non-rich end up paying way
more than they need to because it's
impossible to navigate the tax code
without high-priced accountants
i would agree with you there and that is
an argument for simplifying the tax code
and it may be an argument for a flat tax
something easier and the same for
everybody or really
here's is even better it's an argument
for abolishing the irs
and income tax entirely that stack of
three trillion i mentioned
earlier half of that is from the income
tax take it away and the government is
still collecting or rather sucking in
absorbing like a black hole
1.5 trillion dollars a year i think it
should be able to get by on
a poultry 1.5 trillion so get rid of the
income tax for everyone and we no longer
have this problem
or keep it and let it remain complicated
and
labyrinthine in complexity and if we do
that just don't complain
when rich guys like trump take advantage
as any rich person would
including you let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
all right and uh i hope you guys noticed
and appreciated by the way the
my bookcase uh if you're watching on
youtube right now um
by the way subscribe to my youtube
channel if you haven't yet but uh uh the
bookshelf behind me nice
nice and pretty finally you know it had
looked a little bit like a serial
killers
bookshelf would i imagine not so much in
the content of the books but just in the
haphazard way that they were uh all
there or maybe serial killers would
actually
okay let me back up on that i think
serial killers would actually probably
have very neat books
so now it's a serial killer bookshelf
and you can blame my wife for that she
um
or give her credit uh however you look
at it but she because we're selling the
house and so now everything has to look
pretty including my
dingy little office and so now it's um
it does it does well i have to admit
it's a pretty bookshelf finally for the
first time
speaking of making your house look nice
and pretty another way to do that
is with nice artwork paintings on the
wall
and if you want you know if you want to
class up your house i i don't know much
about making house looks not
houses look nice my wife she does all of
that but um
i do know that some nice artwork on the
walls and that's why you need
paintyourlife.com you can get a
professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo
of yours you know if you have a photo of
of the kids or a family a pet
um any photo that means something to you
you send it to them
and they're going to make this is not a
photoshop deal this is they have real
artists very talented they're going to
render that into a piece of art you can
choose from a team of world-class
artists and work with them until
every detail is perfect it's a
user-friendly platform lets you order a
custom-made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes
quick and easy and there's a lot of back
and forth a lot of feedback
you know we got to paint your life
painting we're probably going to get
another one the one we have we love but
what i liked about it was uh just the
experience of going back and forth with
the artist and
all throughout the process you know
they're looking for my feedback and i'm
giving it and um
it was just it was a great experience
all around it's a meaningful it's
personal
and it's a great gift too if you're
looking for a good gift for someone as
we get closer to the holidays
at paintyourlife.com there's no risk if
you don't love the final painting i
think you will but if you don't your
money is refunded guaranteed and right
now at a limited time
offer get twenty percent off your
painting that's right twenty percent off
and free shipping to get this special
offer text the word matt
to sixty four thousand that's matt sixty
four thousand text matt
att to 64 000 paint your life celebrate
the mat the moments that matter
most okay well this should come as a
shock
to no one really um in fact if you're a
thinking person it shouldn't in fact i
i predicted exactly this a week ago
and i'm barely a thinking person but
it's good to have some confirmation
so according to the attorney of the
officer involved in the jacob blake
shooting
the officer thought um you know going
back to that day
um the officer thought that jacob blake
was trying to kidnap a child
in fact the woman who called 9-1-1 that
would be blake's alleged rape victim
and ex-girlfriend was was screaming
according to the officer she was
screaming
he's got my kid he's got my keys and he
did he had the he had the
the his alleged victims keys to her car
and that's the car that he was trying to
get in it wasn't his car it was it was
the car
didn't belong him he was trying to steal
it apparently um and she does what she
was indicating she was indicating that
he was trying to steal the kids
and the car now as i said it was clear
from the beginning
that there was probably some kind of
domestic thing going on here involving
the kids
the officer also says that blake had a
knife had been fighting with the cops we
knew all of that
but now we also know according to the
officer anyway that and this is
consistent with the facts of the case
and everything we've seen with the
consistent with the evidence that blake
was trying to get into a car
not his car with a knife
evade a rest and drive away with three
kids
no way the officers could let him do
that so you know what
even even take take
the knife out of it resisting arrest
everything
um just the idea of of letting a man
who is wanted for crimes wanted for
domestic abuse and sexual assault
uh to get into a car that is not his
and to evade arrest by driving away with
kids who he doesn't even we can presume
doesn't have custody of
there's just no way you can allow a
person to do that if you're a police
officer you can't allow him to do that
you have to and
any measure must be taken to prevent
that and they tried non-lethal measures
you may remember they tried to tase them
it didn't work
he resisted and the attorney argues and
he's right that
if the officers had not shot and blake
had gotten into the car and driven away
and then something had happened to those
kids everybody would be blaming the
officers for not doing more to save them
and you know what else
we could pretty much guarantee it they
they would still be they'd be accused of
of racism
even then because then they'd be said
that it would be said that uh well they
didn't care enough about black children
so
because they're racist and so they let
this guy drive away and then something
horrible happened to kids
we all know that's what would happen so
the moment those officers arrived on the
scene
it was a lose-lose situation it didn't
matter what happened
lose lose but it looks like those
officers did
the right thing anyway uh not just so
it's not just that they shouldn't be
blamed or you know they didn't commit a
crime it's that they they acted
heroically
to save these innocent children
um and they should be given a lot of
credit for that number two
it was made official on saturday judge
amy cody barrett is trump's nominee for
the supreme court uh here he is
announcing the news
today it is my honor to nominate one of
our nation's most brilliant
and gifted legal minds to the supreme
court
she is a woman of unparalleled
achievement
towering intellect sterling credentials
and unyielding loyalty to the
constitution
judge amy coney barrett
of course the left as expected did its
thing jumping into action
finding ways to smear barrett's which
which is no easy task
because like trump said she's a
respected and brilliant judge she's a
loving mother impeccable credentials
everyone likes her good looking woman i
mean the total package so
what do you do how do you go about this
well fortunately if you're a lunatic
with the moral sensibilities of a
tapeworm
then it's not much of a challenge to
attack a woman even a woman like this
so here's here's a ibram ex candy
anti-racism expert supposedly the guy we
mentioned you may remember him last week
we mentioned him he got
he got paid 20 grand from a school
district in virginia to do a skype
session
where he talked about why white people
are bad and he got paid 20 000
so this this guy's got a nice little
racket going and
he uh chimed in to explain um
why in fact uh barrett
adopt because she's she's also an
adoptive mother she's a mother she's
adopted um
uh i believe two children and
he's explaining why barrett adopting
black children
something that most people would see as
a mark in her favor character-wise
um is not in fact it's the opposite she
he says some white colonizers
adopted black children they civilized
quote these
savage children in the superior ways of
white people
while using them as prompts in their
lifelong pictures of denial
while cutting the biological parents of
these children out of the picture of
humanity
um that's what he had to say about that
that's how he looks at
adoption most of us we look at and i
watch this
and it really did appear to be just a
wonderful
beautiful loving family sincerely you
know i know that
politicians and people that are in the
political scene which unfortunately now
supreme court justices are whether they
should be or not and they shouldn't be
but you know they all try to give the
impression of having wonderful loving
fully intact families and we know that
oftentimes that's certainly not the case
but in this case it really seems to be
it's just a loving
good wholesome family most of us see
that and that's how we feel about it but
people on the left they look at it and
they're
somehow they're disgusted by it
so this is what they're going to go with
they're really going to go with this
she's racist
because she has black children because
she has black children that's that's the
line of attack
you know like we talked about with trump
before you know it's like they have all
this this stuff on him and
and they haven't found that really
really found where the bodies are buried
so it makes us
think maybe there are no bodies well
even more so with amy coney barrett that
they're coming through her life looking
desperately for something
they'll take anything they can and what
they have to settle on
is attacking her because she adopted
kids
that tells you how how clean uh her
record must really be
impressive number three well the
election is basically over now folks i
think i know we haven't even had the
debate yet that's happening tomorrow but
i think this sort of seals the deal
for joe biden because the moment we've
been waiting for
has happened dwayne the rock johnson
has given his endorsement watch
happy sunday everybody we are
approximately five weeks away
from election day arguably the most
critical election
our country has seen in decades now that
said
i'm going to be pushing this political
conversation uh just a little bit more
now you know look i've got friends in
all parties but the one thing that we
can
always agree on is the conversation and
the dialogue and where that conversation
lands
is always the most critical part now
this is something that i've certainly
not done in the past
so i'm gonna go big you guys know me if
i go
i go big so guys i had the opportunity
to sit down
with vice president joe biden and
senator kamala harris to talk about
a number of important issues that we're
facing as a country
i thought it was a great and extremely
productive conversation that we had and
as a registered independent for years
now with
census centrist excuse me ideologies
i do feel that vice president biden and
senator harris
are the best choice to lead our country
and i am endorsing them to become
president and vice president of our
united states
okay now just a few a few quick points
if i may first
look i'm in no position to body shame
the rock
uh he he could quite clearly snap me in
half with his pinkies
i'm sure but at the same time i do feel
like the muscular physique gets a little
bit absurd at a certain point
doesn't it just you you cross through a
threshold at a certain point
where it's like okay dude just relax
take it down a notch take it i get the
point just take it down a few notches
and i think the rock is teetering close
to that line it's it's a little much is
all i'm saying
that's it that's all i'm trying to say
um
second point probably more to the point
why did joe biden sit down with the rock
uh i mean and when did this have biden
has been working two hours
two hour days for the last like 19 weeks
he calls it a lid on the day
at 9 30 a.m most mornings and yet he had
time to meet with dwayne the rock
johnson
is that why he was calling a lid in
order to have extensive
meetings with the rock i'm imagining
five or six hour long meetings every day
for weeks on end
hashing out domestic policy foreign
policy everything with the rock that's
what i'm imagining
but as usual my imagination has no
connection to reality
um actually because we have the
conversation here's what the
conversation between the rock and joe
biden
really sounded like you guys are are
both obviously experienced to lead
you've done great things
joe you've had such an incredible career
you've led in my opinion with great
compassion
and in heart and drive
but also soul and you and i talked about
that in the past and how important soul
is
and uh come live i'm gonna embarrass you
just for a little bit because i'm gonna
talk a little bit about your
uh your amazing experience and you have
been an attorney
a district attorney a state attorney a
u.s
senator smart tough i've seen you in
those hearings
and um in my opinion you are certified
badass
well he he grilled them didn't he he
really
he held their feet to the fire
and but he was also definitely i hope
you noticed that he was definitely
reading
all of that information about camilla
harris
he was he didn't know anything about her
he was saying camilla i know so much
about you
um i've always been a huge supporter for
your whole career in the um
senate yeah a big fan of camilla harris
there i mean
but in fairness to him and this is why i
give him credit i think he has a pretty
good actor
uh to to pretend that you're a big fan
of camila harris
that's no easy task so that's probably
his greatest acting moment
i think was right there number four in
more celebrity news
singer john legend says that he and his
wife chrissy teigen might be kind
might be are thinking of of maybe
leaving the united states if donald
trump is re-elected
um now as many have pointed out this
seems like a bit of an idle threat
considering
they apparently just bought a 17 million
dollar mansion
in in beverly hills not the kind of
thing you do
if you're planning on fleeing a country
because it's become a fascist wasteland
in fact not the kind of thing you could
do probably if it was a fascist
wasteland
but besides that of course um you just
have to reflect on the
psychotic narcissism of these
celebrities
that they think it's some sort of
effective form of blackmail to threaten
to leave the country
as if we're all going to fall to the
ground grabbing at their feet like no
don't leave us please we can't we can't
go on without you
john legend i don't think anyone's gonna
have that reaction
even if you're a fan of john legend what
do you care where he lives what
difference does it make
it's a little similar on a smaller scale
it reminds me of
the thing that people do to me online
all the time they probably it's a com
they probably do it to you too
but on social media i get this kind of
thing all the time on a smaller scale
where
where someone will threaten to unfollow
me or un unfriend me
because i express an opinion they don't
like and my favorite is when they when
they say something like you know i'm
really thinking of unfollowing you now
matt
i'm thinking of it this this opinion
that's got me thinking i might unfollow
and again it's as if i'm supposed to
break down in tears and plead with them
and say no
i'll change i promise don't leave me
it'll be different this time i promise
um we can go to counseling together no
just doesn't doesn't work the threat
doesn't work nobody cares that much
whoever you are whether you're john
legend you're just a normal a random
person on the internet no one cares that
much what you do or what you think so
don't don't try to hold it as a a
bargaining chip
number five finally this is um
interesting from the daily star
always a reputable publication uh it
says real life
inception as scientists figure out how
to plant ideas
in dreams and then it goes on it may
sound like a plot of inception but
scientists have figured out how to plant
ideas into other people's dreams
researchers at mit media labs fluid
interfaces
have been testing a new technique called
targeted dream incubation
which allows them to insert topics into
someone's dream
uh let's see how do they do this the
study involved 25 participants taking
daytime naps before going to bed they
would record audio prompts in an
app such as remember to think of a tree
and remember to observe your thoughts
okay then they just oh okay well that's
a bummer
i thought this would be some kind of
fancy technological thing like hacking
into someone's brain you know
something from the matrix but no they
just they just remind themselves before
going to bed hey i should think of a
tree and then they wake up and say yo i
had a dream about a tree
not i don't know that's why is this a
new revelation
and why is it being studied at all
and and speaking of dreams being being
on a research team where my whole
job is to listen to dream stories from
other people
that's my nightmare that's my personal
nightmare
because there is nothing worse than
listening to someone drone on
about their stupid dream that they think
is so profound and they tell you about
it but really it's just
boring they tell you they say oh man i
had a dream last night where i was
walking down the road
and then the road turned into a snake
pit
and uh then the snakes turned into candy
canes
and i and i and i started to fly and
next thing you know ronald reagan was
there and no
stop first of all you're embellishing
half of this and i can tell
second i don't care um dreams are only
interesting to the dreamer
to everyone else a dream is just bad
storytelling
rule of thumb we should take that with
us all of us dreams are canceled
before we get to our real daily
cancellation which we'll get to in just
a second
but first um as mentioned the debate is
tomorrow night
fight night at 9 00 pm eastern 6 pm
pacific donald trump and joe biden will
face off in the first of three
presidential debates this election
season
will biden fall asleep will trump wear a
mask
many questions and you could join us for
an all new episode of daily wire
backstage to watch the debate with us
and get our immediate live reaction to
this major political event and even
better join daily wire now as an insider
or all access member get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
the al all uh
all the debate coverage live on our
apple tv or roku app
members get our articles ad free access
to our live broadcast the show library
the full three hours of the benchmark
show
exclusive reader pass readers pass
content available only to daily wire
members
and if you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for online
live stream discussions those are a lot
of fun so watch the debate with us on
dailywire.com youtube facebook get 20
off your daily wire membership with code
debate when you sign up today
all right let's get to our daily
cancellation a quick daily cancellation
today we're going to cancel
jill philopovic a noted feminist who
being a feminist commits a cancelable
infractions every day but this one
actually has
little to do with feminism here's what
she tweeted um i know the thing parents
hate most is when non-parents assert
what they will do as parents
which is evidently smug and incorrect
but i am 100 sure i will never ascend to
a kid's menu or the concept of kid food
and then she continues everyone who is
like oh this is so unrealistic just wait
until you're a parent
do you think children in most of the
world order off of the kids menu and
survive primarily off of chicken fingers
and plain pasta
that's what she said now i'm not
interested in spending much time
discussing the merits of the children's
menu i can only tell you that as a
parent the four children ages seven and
younger
not only do i not avoid places with
children's menus but i won't take my
family there
unless they have a children's menu in
fact what i'm really looking for is a
restaurant with a children's menu
that gives out crayons before the you
know for the kids to use before the food
comes out
and that's that is loud and obnoxious
and filled with whiny
crying kids throwing chicken nuggets all
over the place squirting ketchup on the
walls
i want a restaurant that is just a
nightmare of loud noises and
questionable smells
for me as a parent that's going to be
the least stressful
least anxiety-inducing environment
because it means
i don't have to worry about my own kids
being loud and obnoxious
i know they'll fit right in the worst
thing imaginable is when you go to a
restaurant with a bunch of kids
and you walk in and it's quiet and
there's a bunch of older people without
children eating and they have like fancy
cloth napkins at the table
and and the entrees have names you can't
pronounce and there's no children's menu
and they don't sell corndogs or boneless
chicken wings
that's when you know you're in for a
stressful dining experience
those are one of the most stressful
moments as a parent of young kids every
noise your child makes will reverberate
through the establishment and if say
your seven-year-old son makes a fart
noise which causes your three-year-old
son to laugh hysterically and make his
own fart noises
um the older couple at the table to your
right will
look and shake their heads with horror
as if this is the first time they've
ever been in the vicinity of young boys
and this is what you have to deal with
so as a parent that's what you're trying
to avoid at all costs
no give me loud dirty cheap
unhealthy that's what i want in my
dining establishments if i have kids
with me
because that's where i know i'm home but
that's all a side issue really the real
point is that we have here the classic
faux pas that even jill herself
acknowledges you know she she not
acknowledges what she's getting herself
into
this is a non-parent making a confident
declaration about what she will
do or not do when she's a parent all
non-parents do this
all current parents did do this before
they were parents
and and we all regret having done it we
all look back on our past
selves when we said things like when i'm
a parent my kids will never eat sugary
cereal or when i'm a parent my kids will
never watch tv or
when i'm a parent my kids will never
walk through the grocery store and bare
feet because they lost their third pair
of shoes this week and i was so fed up
with it that i said fine you're just
going to walk around without shoes all
day if that's what you want
and we think back to that and we laugh
at ourselves and we wish that we could
reach back
through time and space and grab
ourselves by the shoulders and shake
ourselves and say stop talking you fool
you know not what you say but we can't
so we are stuck with what we said doomed
forever to carry the yoke of our past
ignorance
let me give you an example for my for my
my own life
i can remember as a non-parent when i
used to drive in my car and driving in
my car as a non-parent
like everything else was easy and
carefree i could listen to music i could
maybe listen to an audio book
i could roll down the windows and enjoy
the breeze it was quiet it was tranquil
just me in the open road and i remember
sometimes my tranquility would be
interrupted
when i would end up behind a minivan in
traffic and i would notice that it had a
tv
and the tv was playing cartoons or a
disney movie or something
and then i would always shake my head
and say ah what a shame tv in the car
the car is a time for quiet reflection
or fruitful conversation not tv
those parrots are clearly inferior to
the parent that i will be when i am a
parent
yes when i'm a parent i shall never let
my kids watch tv in the car
it will never happen and then i had kids
at first i stuck with my previous
pronouncement mainly because i didn't
have a tv
in our car at the time so it was sort of
easy but after a few years we purchased
a chevy suburban that
has a tv that drops down from the
ceiling and i remember saying to my wife
upon purchasing the vehicle
as i tried desperately to remain
obedient to the pointless rule i had set
for myself
i said to my wife we are not going to
use this thing
i forbid it and i stuck to my words on
that
valiantly for about three hours
but you know the thing about kids in the
car is that they're a lot like kids
outside the car
except now you're stuck in a metal box
with them as you careen down the road at
high speeds
there isn't going to be any quiet
reflection and if there's any
conversation in that environment it will
be fruitful
only in spurts but most of the
conversation will revolve around
philosophical questions like are we
there yet can i have a snack
i need to pee luke called me a poopy
head other similar topics
all coming at you relentlessly for hours
on end
unless you put on the tv and like magic
it all stops
and you realize now that that
you're the one in the car rather than
being the judgmental pretentious
know-nothing and the quiet peaceful
sedan behind you
and you realize that there actually
isn't any particularly good reason not
to turn the tv on other than out of some
weird sense of principle but it's a
principle grounded more
in the need you felt as a non-parent to
believe
that your hypothetical parenting skills
were superior to the actual parenting
skills of actual parents
so you turn on the tv and you enjoy the
silence
at least as much as you can because now
instead of listening to the kids fight
you have to listen to scooby-doo
it's a trade-off not a perfect one but
you'll take it
there are a lot of trade-offs like that
in parenting but that's a
simply a reality that you that you you
can't fully appreciate or realize until
you have kids
until you're down there in the trenches
with them
every single day of your life so what i
would recommend if you're not a parent
just
seriously take it from me never say
anything about what you will or won't do
when you have kids nothing i don't care
how obvious you think it is
because you never know just don't say
one damn word and then you could go into
into parenting when you finally have
kids
without dealing with the judgmental gaze
of your own past self
that's my tip and uh so yeah jill
philippevic is is cancelled and and
all non-parents who say stuff like this
are cancelled so which means i'm
canceled you know we're okay everyone's
canceled it's another one of those
we're all canceled okay we'll leave it
there um
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton